happy thursday my wonderful partners in
life
so great news as the border dissolves
like a sandcastle on the beach inflation
soars and crime runs rampant what's the
department of homeland security consumed
with
i'll give you a hint it ain't homeland
security it's what you have to say about
them and their failures apparently
there's thin skinned as nancy pelosi's
eyelids
yesterday in a hearing on immigration
that bald fellow with the adorable ears
announced the disinformation governance
board in order to combat online
misinformation you know because the real
problems we face apparently are our
opinions not our incompetent actions
it's like blaming fires on the fire
department i mean they always seem to be
around right after i start one
just recently constituted a
misinformation disinformation governance
board so we're bringing
the goal is to bring the resources of
the department together to address this
threat
fun fact he had hair like fabio before
he worked with kamala harris
and why does he remind me of this guy
i just want to squeeze his head like a
pastry bag filled with whipped cream
and that would be the beginning
well i hope they found a good person to
head up the board someone who could tell
the difference between real and fake who
can objectively judge evidence and
refrain from making snap decisions
without any proof
oh it's nina jankowicz
she's directing the board i wouldn't
trust her to direct a paulie shore movie
she just shared her official government
portrait on her social media profile
cat's out of the bag she said but really
whoever picked her had to be half in the
bag to select this doofus she's further
to the left than the green monster at
fenway
the baseball reference cat
i know my sports in case you're unaware
jankowitz had questioned the validity of
hunter biden's laptop early on actually
calling it a trump campaign product
which raises some questions one how is
she an expert and two you got to be
kidding me
how could she even qualify for this job
if she got that wrong oh i forgot we're
talking about a bite administration job
what are they going to do next put kamal
in charge of the southern border
and you got to wonder how did this
expert base her opinion on the laptop
was it her own opinion or was it handed
to her the way joe was handed the
presidency it's the biggest
disinformation story of the past two
years aside from whoever convinced cnn
to start a streaming service
that was me
was she aware that when she spouted her
disinformation she would affect an
election maybe that was the whole point
and later when it's abundantly clear she
was wrong why isn't she owned up to it
i admit when i'm wrong or at least i'm
prepared to if that ever happens
but she knew she lied to get trump out
and biden in and she's running this
thing remember as much as they say that
they hate disinformation the real
doozies come from them i mean does
alejandro remember whip gate that was
this information biden exploited and
then amplified demonizing a dhs employee
a border dude on horseback accusing him
of whipping haitian migrants now he
didn't have to be a long-standing member
of one of the few s m clubs located
right here in midtown manhattan
to know those were whips
i mean it's nothing like a leather
flogger
but they conducted an investigation on
it and once they realized their
information turned out to be as legit as
rupaul's eyelashes they said nothing and
this should piss you off they're
creating a ministry of information under
the guise of protecting you when really
they're targeting you instead
you can't trust these people to monitor
disinformation that's like trusting
brian stelter to guard your donut
or asking joy behar to keep an eye on
your broomstick
it's like begging hunter to keep an eye
on your eight ball
that was my mistake
it's like trusting norman bates to
recommend a decent bed and breakfast
jagowicz is also a lefty clone even
echoing manic liberal reaction to musk
buying twitter if she ever came up with
a thought of her own it would die of
loneliness she told npr that she
shudders to think about more free speech
after musk bought twitter and wondered
if the first amendment is a good thing
for marginalized communities and by
marginalized communities she means
people who think jokes are acts of
violence while acts of violence are well
free speech
i shudder to think about if free speech
absolutists were taking over more
platforms what that would look like for
the marginalized communities all around
the world which are already shouldering
so much of this abuse disproportionate
amounts of this abuse
so much
she also recommended the government
spend your money on a robust public
media imagine that all the boredom of
npr with the efficiency of the
department of motor vehicles
and as i'm biased as will smith
reviewing a jada pinkett movie she also
plotted twitter's efforts to censor
users during the 2020 election saying
the platform moved in the right
direction which really means moving so
far left mao would say
let's think this over
i wonder when this will come to the
workplace
hi everyone welcome to the first meeting
of the gutfeld disinformation board so
does anyone have any uh complaints uh
yeah so last week when i was trapped in
that elevator and you told greg i was in
cancun isn't that disinformation i mean
you can see me on the elevator security
camera
first of all i'm i am so sorry that you
feel that way um but we all know that
unlike time travel elevators haven't
been invented yet right uh cat last time
i was on panel you promised i could get
into hair and makeup and you were in
there for six hours having your hair
extensions done oh whoa my hair is real
look i think we can all agree that greg
is the guilty one here right i mean
remember when he said we couldn't have
any bathroom breaks because covid lives
in your pee
hey everybody sorry i'm late we can
start the disinfo meeting now
oh there you go
so it appears
it appears this white house is trying to
create a new shiny arm of government to
crack down on stuff they don't want to
hear the goal to police your opinions to
hide their bad news or magically turn it
into good news
hey inflation's good for the economy the
crime rate is actually going down
carjacking is really assertive
carpooling
i wonder what their motto will be here's
my suggestion if you like your opinion
you can keep your opinion
let's welcome tonight's guest we call
her the georgia peach because she was
born in atlanta and keeps throwing fruit
in my head host of the [ __ ] focus and
cohost of outnumbered harris [ __ ]
wow
his show starts so early it should be
called fox and friends and meth
co-host of fox and friends first todd
pyro
[Applause]
crowds tell him to quit his day job and
the hope that he starves
after writer and comedian jamie lisa
and finally she never gets phased even
while being tased fox news contributor
cat tim
paris harris harris harris harris harris
harris stop
not the vice president
and i said i want my name back this
whole week has been about about speech
freedom of speech and we're seeing lines
being drawn what do you make of this
disinformation well first of all we got
to see what that was going to look like
today a lot of it will be can you watch
the shiny object over there so my orcis
was on the hill as this disinformation
governance panel was being rolled out
today and he and representative jim
jordan were really getting into it jim
jordan of ohio right he said of all the
terrorists that have been released are
there any going about the country or did
you send them down south and
below the border well i i can provide
that so that's not a no and i mean it
got really really heated and it was
right about the time that we were
learning a lot of information about nina
jankovic yeah it's convenient day two
and the timing of this right and i don't
believe in coincidences i believe in
interesting timing and it was
interesting for him although the seat
just got hotter it's so funny i was
thinking the same thing
that was what i was going to say
[Laughter]
must be some part of a bigger plan jamie
how you doing over there i'm great yeah
you're far away i wish you were closer
no
that's sweet
i wish there were wheels on this thing
yeah wow that's awesome what do you make
of this disinformation uh
whatever what is it called it's a it's a
board it's a board
i was like so excited about elon that i
ignorantly thought like everyone would
be excited and it was just so
disappointing and just remind me like
the the hunter biden laptop thing is
insane and i will say that did get me a
little bit like paranoid just
remembering that story like i get so
paranoid about my laptop like i don't
know if you do this but i always put
like i use a little piece of black tape
to cover my
is that penis real life or projected on
the screen like are they the same sorry
just so nobody knows it's me yes
[Music]
but exciting about i'm i am legitimately
excited about elon on twitter come on
this is exciting stuff hardest part of
the contract was getting it down to 280
characters oh you
yeah yeah
went from a beautiful joke to just that
could i try to recover with one more yes
please so i just watch this one i get
excited because i feel like a rich guy
doing doing big things is exciting to
watch right right yeah and so because
elon had he's got fu money yes you know
what i mean like someday i just hope to
have i respectfully disagree money yes
nice recovery yeah that's not bad that's
not better we'll get it to the judges
later
todd how are you doing i'm okay how are
you i'm doing great i'm doing great you
look great thank you you as well uh you
went to see the yankees today i did greg
caught me i should have been preparing
but i came fully dressed like derek
jeter back to the studio he's one of
those guys that wears the jersey player
that he likes which is not at all
obsessive and strange
what do you make of this like how could
they have picked somebody this obviously
biased to run this thing i think it goes
beyond that obviously she's an activist
but i want to focus on the russian
expert part of her portfolio she is
probably a russian expert in light of
the fact that she dismissed the 300 byte
and stuff like i'm an expert in dance
yes i am not an expert in dance just
look at me uh but one of the key things
that i found and nobody's really talking
about
the focus of this disinformation group
is going to be the hispanic community
because there's concern about
misinformation radicalization and
election misinformation with regard to
this community could this have anything
to do with i don't know recent polling
showing hispanics are flocking to the
gop in record numbers flocking and
potentially voting republican is
disinformation clearly in the eyes of
the biden administration and nina
jankowicz
crazy crazy cat i tell you what is your
thought on taxes paying for a
disinformation board that will likely
target you yeah well i'm against taxes
and those already target me yes they do
uh but i just don't understand
who would trust that something's true
just because the government says it's
true because nobody has the ability to
be able to lie like the government
because they have power over all of us
and i don't see how anyone could want
this
like okay yeah you can't say that that's
not true because we say it's not true if
like if this was if this was a trump
thing i think it would be like a massive
meltdown over this of course a massive
meltdown over there i would and i would
be melting down over it no matter who
the president was because that's the
whole point is that you should be you're
allowed to think and say whatever you
want to and there's this is government
sanctioned speech in a way and that
actually that's exactly what it is you
know they have lost and and you brought
up this point loosely they have lost
what they thought was going to be the
gatekeeper on that they've lost twitter
yeah and so you know now it's like well
what do we do by the way this is based
on a center that already exists within
the administration they don't have the
power of any punitive damages against
you all they can do is watch you but in
my book i'm like you cat that's enough
to make me feel unnerved yeah you know i
don't i i mean i used to like being
watched but as i've gotten older
i prefer to okay that's not what i meant
sometimes i don't understand you you
know i said this earlier we should start
testing them
we should start finding out what the the
little uh tripwires are by saying things
on the show that could be considered as
disinformation just to see what what
just to drive him crazy i've got one
what wuhan laboratory origin possibly
potentially most likely and probably
will be
coveted 19. there you go and that'll get
you stickered and suspended i'm just
saying exactly
i'm gonna think of some more during the
break
all right before we go this is so
exciting we're welcoming back our studio
audience in a brand new studio that
could blow your mind that's this monday
may 2nd and we have a show that is
insane like real guests not like jamie
free tickets
free tickets are available right now
go to foxes.com
for info hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else